l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj prima di
cominciare di ritmi storia con la parola
della settimana che allora questa
settimana non è una fan art finita
perché paolo si chiamava paolo ha fatto
questa cosa
ok ecco e non è ancora finita
dovete capire il mio il mio bisogno di
vedere finita questa cosa paolo che stai
guardando questo video perché lo stai
guardando corrie fini veloce nel
frattempo che attendiamo con ansia che
finisca il disegni e ricominciare con i
blog di oggi allora prima di partire ago
devo dirvi ragazzi che questo blog
andrò ad aprire una scatola special
in poche parole mi sono fatto arrivare
dal giappone in questa bellissima
scatola rosa delle caramelle speciali
giapponesi quindi me la lascio un attimo
da parte che vi dico due cose e poi
andiamo ad e scatolare insieme non so
cosa ci sia dentro che una sorpresa in
realtà ti mandano questo pacco non sai
contenuto volevo dirvi che questa
settimana parto per le vacanze sto via
una settimana da da oggi fino a sabato
prossimo vado in spagna così almeno gli
stalker che mi seguono anche mentre va
dal cesso sanno che se devono seguirmi
devono venire in spagna altra cosa che
volevo dirvi perché non vi ho spiegato
ancora nulla quindi mi sembra giusto
farlo dedichiamo qualche parola allo
zaino quello del video dell'altro ieri
allo ragazzi vi spiego è sì uscito il
mio zaia e lo zaino di fi jtv col logo
di fa vj quindi per questo qua questo ha
dato dentro ha ottenuto il quel coso di
youtube dove quando e uscito lo zaino
ho dovuto ovviamente comunicarvelo per
far capire caro originale perché sono
andate di pone nei negozi li vedete
ditemi che fa vi hanno fatto il tuo
zaino è che grazie al caso l'ho
disegnato io non l'ho fatto io non è che
mi sono messo lì a cucire tutti gli
zaini che ci sono però questa parte da
va anzi data tutto anche questo anche i
televisori qua è stata una mia scelta di
design per lozza perché volevo fare un
qualche cosa che fosse ideato da me ora
siccome non volevo fare un video
semplice nel quale dicevo ai ragazzi che
bello è uscito lo zaino andate a brand
che due palle come dire ai ragazzi che è
uscito il mio zaino in modo carino e ho
pensato quindi di fare un video quello
che avete visto dove io prendo per il
culo lo zaino stesso ci fa scomparire le
persone che non
pero credo un sacco di voi tra l'altro
mi stanno mandando foto che avete lo
zaino avete già tuchel in realtà prima
che uscisse il video si arrangia tutti
devo solo dirlo io ci ho messo un po di
tempo a farlo perché volevo che il video
uscisse bene perché doveva far ridere
quindi vi ringrazio perché ormai è già
zio mio ce l'ha anche mia nonna davvero
oltre che in quella inoltre che non
avant hellas dei ragazzi l'ultima news
novi tartassi maroni che lamenta bassa
ve la dico alla fine passiamo alla de
scatola zione la pina cosa [ __ ] che
nutriamo dalla scatole che mi ha
riammesso un mese da un mese pensavo che
mi avessero [ __ ] all'inizio invece un
cavo aymon freebox from tokyo che cosa
c'è dentro la mia scatola che cosa c'è
nel mio zaino e cosa c'è nel mio
cervello un cazzo io lo so che devo
aspettarmi il peggio lo so ho visto più
o meno come sono fatte le caramelle che
spediscono e sono strane tanto che già
l'apertura dà da pensare che cazzo ho
fatto una genialata a prendere questa
cosa gli wings va bene dovete capire
l'epicità di questa scatola
oddio non ci credo mai lo girerò mai
vabbè ciao no vabbè vi adoro e
meraviglio vabbè alla prima cosa è alpa
chiasso e ovviamente tutto originale
giapponese infatti non si capisce un
cazzo
alpa che associa già questo vale la
scatola solo questo dopodichè ragazzi
abbiamo una penna e ha però ci fossero
solo caramelle dentro una penna il logo
è super tenero una penna
credo sia commestibile e una roba molle
fu detta ma quell omino è fantastico non
ho la più pallida idea di che cosa sia
ma andiamo ad aprirlo che sono curioso
non credo o di santo ed io non credo si
magni qualcuno di voi mi spiega che
cos'è sta roba perché c'è un tipo
intrappolato in una bolla la non è
commestibile però le molle dopodiché i
ragazzi c'è questa cosa che non si
capisce un cazzo pro apriamo o la prima
cosa commestibile l'ho trovata melosa di
mela porca eva già tantissimo di mela
buonissimo la prima roba commestibile
l'abbiamo [ __ ] pensavo di avere un
pacco di dolci un cazzo d'america
ragazzi cè un portachiavi cos'è sta roba
io provate care tutto per adesso è
commestibile non è commestibile un
bavaglino equa mi hanno identificato
subito ma cos'è ma cos'è sta roba
la mia vita è completa fantastico a
perfetto familiari trovato la sua vera
natura
dopodichè ragazzi c'è pon pon pur in pon
pon purini in una prima lettura avevo
letto ho sbagliato a leggere ma sono
sono adesivi per ultima cosa ragazzi
un'altra credo sia un agenda anche
questa forse è come ultimo ragazzi
ultimo ma non per importanza 1 vari fura
wow wow ha neanche questo è commestibile
io ero come qualcosa che avevo detto
parco di caramelle resta solo questo a
qualcuno mi spiega che cos'è sta roba vi
prego no bisogno fatemi sapere ragazzi
se l'utente che io prenda altri pacchi
del genere perde scatola rli in diretta
perché mi sembrava carina l'idea niente
direi che possiamo proseguire allora
ragazzi la gnosi che volevo darvi in
conclusione non so se posso dirvelo di
costi gaza io e email stiamo abbiamo già
organizzato un viaggio in giappone che
faremo dal 13 al 23 settembre ci sarà
anche l'ultra japan che è una
sottospecie di tomorrowland che si tiene
in giappone ma soprattutto io vado in
giappone perché fanno questi che tra
l'altro nel ultimi di jean jacques e ci
sono di con che questo mi avete detto ma
che cazzo è sta roba che al collo io
ragazzi li ammazzerei come fate a non
sapere che cos'è il gira tempo ma che
infanzia avete e un ciondolo che usa
in harry potter per farti tornare
indietro nel tempo quando fai così
magari no quello era un horror erano dei
capelli che poi in argomento harry
potter non so se lo sapete ma sta
uscendo la maledizione delle red e se
voi potete capire quanto io sia in ansia
è già uscita in inghilterra ma devo
aspettare la versione italiana sono
capisco la metà non vivo più fino a che
non esce mi chiederà avete idea pavè
sorvoliamo pavè ragazzoni direi che
posso concludere qui con il video di
oggi scusate se un po breve però avevo
partire veramente tra pochissimo quindi
non posso stare troppo tempo a montarlo
ti suona ambigua questa frase che i
ragazzi sentitevi è piaciuto ma se il
tas ha un documento mi piace un mi piace
anche per al pac asso che cazzo se li
merita anche la pagina di facebook come
nei video trattare descrizione questi
scrittori ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazzi